[Music]
so
without further ado i'd like to
introduce our first speaker will chase
speaking on the glamour of graphics
all right so uh thank you for coming
today everyone and welcome to my talk on
the glamour of graphics which is a talk
on the
design of charts so if you recognize me
it's probably from twitter
i tweet excessively and you may also
recognize my website
williamrchase.com where i post lots of
blogs about art and generative art how
to make it an
r r tutorials all sorts of stuff like
that
so professionally i come from academia
i worked at penn state and then upenn
for many years and now recently i've
joined fidelity investments
as a senior visualization analyst
where i'm focusing on visual design and
storytelling within our organization
i also do freelance data visualization
so if you're interested in talking about
that
please get in touch now the glamour of
graphics that i'm going to be talking
about today was actually inspired by
kelly baudwin as i say i tweet
excessively so this is where i got the
inspiration
and that led me to spend one of my
saturdays um
making this glamour magazine spoof which
i think was probably my most viral tweet
ever and
i may be the first person to get invited
to talk at our studio conf based on a
twitter meme that i made
so i'm pretty proud of that but i think
that there's actually some substance
here so this said take your charts from
drab to fab and that's sort of what
we're going to try to do today
so this is the drab this is the starting
point right sorry hadley but
it's true and what we're going to try to
do is get something more
like this um so a little bit about what
this talk is not
it's not a talk about chart shaming so
uh you'll see a lot of design mistakes
that i'm going to talk about today but
if you go to my blog and look at my
portfolio you will see
all of those mistakes featured heavily
there
it's also not a talk about tools or
about what charts to use in terms of
like data visualization it's really
focused on the aesthetics
so the reason you should care about
aesthetics and charts is pretty obvious
to me but it will help you
engage a much wider audience with your
work it'll actually help your work to be
perceived as more usable and more
intuitive
so it's actually been shown that charts
that are more aesthetically pleasing
are perceived by users to be more
intuitive and finally it'll just let you
show respect for your audience you know
people spend their time
looking at your charts you should spend
time making them look nice
so when i started researching this i
thought it was sort of just a
coincidence oh
grammar of graphics glamour of graphics
haha but
um it turns out that the word glamour is
actually derived from the word grammar
so back in the middle ages the word
grammar meant
all learning and that included things
like magic and occult
and through the ages that word sort of
morphed into glamour and as it did it
lost the association with knowledge and
it became to mean just a magical spell
actually and then eventually in the 18th
century the idea of magic
sort of washed away a little bit and we
got the meaning that we know today which
is this sort of
exciting illusory romantic
attractiveness
so the grammar of graphics is a tool
that enables us to concisely describe
the components of a graphic
and what i'm going to do today is try to
bring this sort of illusory romantic
quality of glamour
a little bit closer to a grammar so i'm
going to describe a tool that enables us
to concisely describe the design of a
graphic
so in the grammar of graphics we have
these three components
of data aesthetics and geometries that
are really the core of any chart
and i know there's more layers but this
is really you know the core of how to
describe a chart
what i'm going to describe in the
glamour of graphics is similar but i'm
going to describe
three layers that you need to describe
the design of a graphic and that's the
layout the typography and the color
so beginning with layout i'm going to
talk about three main concepts
today and that is alignment white space
and grids lines and borders
so beginning with alignment i want to
talk about titles first
titles should be top left aligned
usually
and when i say top left aligned i don't
mean the case that you see on the left
where you have left aligned with your
data i mean left aligned
all the way to the edge of your chart to
create a nice clean line with the edge
of your chart
now previously this was actually kind of
tricky to do with ggplot but luckily in
the development version we have a new
argument
that makes this very very simple to do
next i want you to please not make me do
like this when i read your chart so i
see this a lot of times
especially in academic graphics where
you have these really long x-axis labels
nobody wants to do that so of course
it's always better if you can to flip
our coordinates horizontally
or if you can't manage to flip it you
can just try to make the text horizontal
by increasing your spacing and such
this is a little more controversial
maybe but i also think it's actually
best practice
not to use vertical axis labels because
you have the same problem
so you can do the same thing you can try
to make the text just horizontal
or a lot of times you can get rid of
access labels entirely
a lot of access labels are completely
unnecessary things like dates
in this case suv minivam it's obvious
these are types of cars
and usually by just including a good
title you can do away with axis labels
so when you're thinking about alignment
you should always try to create a
clean lines and symmetry and what i want
to go over is a little bit
this graphic from 538 that i think
really illustrates some of these points
so this doesn't have big blocks of text
but just to mention if you do have big
blocks of text like an infographic or
something
you want to left align those most likely
left alignment should sort of be your
default
right alignment can be used for labels a
lot of times so especially like
horizontal bar labels where the goal is
to create a clean line with the edge of
your data
and sometimes subtitles or labels can be
center aligned if it helps to create
symmetry
within the graphic so in this case you
can see
actually the designer made a mistake on
the 2014 one it should be center aligned
but it's slightly off center
but if you look at the rest of the
graphic you can see how this left
alignment right alignment and center
alignment sort of creates this perfect
symmetry within the graphic
so charts often come with these
extraneous elements
they're not data and a lot of times they
can distract
from the chart so i want to talk a
little bit about how to reduce those
a good example of this is borders you
almost never need a border in a chart
oftentimes they just don't serve a
purpose and all they do is distract from
your data add
ink to the page another thing is grid
lines um
i understand that there's reasons to
have grid lines sometimes
but i encourage you to always question
the purpose of every grid line do you
need
horizontal grid lines in every case do
you need minor grid lines
if not please remove them if you do need
them
i encourage you to make them as light
and as
small as possible so that they sort of
disappear into the background rather
than distracting from your data
another thing that distracts from your
data a lot is legends
particularly when you have like a big
blob of a legend off to the right-hand
side of your chart
it's not a very good flow within your
chart so i recommend if you have legends
you put them right below the titles
where it creates a nice flow with your
chart
a better solution even is to directly
label your data
or my favorite solution is to use
colored text
to indicate your legend in the title and
this will now be possible with the new
grid text package which i think klaus is
talking about this afternoon
so a few words about white space
this is particularly relevant when
you're looking at things like dashboards
and infographics where you're laying out
a lot of charts together
and what i often see is people want to
cram as much information as they can
possibly get onto the page
but what that ends up ends up resulting
in is that you can't
even understand any of it your eye has
no
idea where to go on the page and so your
charts really need room to breathe
so i always recommend it's like garlic
you take as much white space as you
think you need and then
triple it that's sort of the foundation
of building a nice chart is the layout
and next up i'm going to talk
about typography so typography is a very
sort of vast
subject it has a lot of details in it
and i can't cover them all today but
what i highly highly recommend you do is
go to
practicaltypography.com this is a
completely free open source
online book that will basically teach
you everything you could need to know
about typography
in a very concise way it'll take about
three hours to read cover to cover and
it will vastly improve the design of
everything that you write
but i do want to touch a little bit on
fonts hierarchy and a couple of datavis
specific concerns
so the font that you choose really
matters in a chart it
especially affects the tone of your
graphic right you can send a completely
different message based on the font you
choose
and it can also really affect the
legibility of your graphic right it's
pretty easy to have
misunderstandings if you choose the
wrong font
so this is important
and the unfortunate thing is that most
people will just go for the system font
the default font
and that's sad because most system fonts
are pretty terrible i'm sorry to tell
you
most of them were designed for the
screens that we had in the 1990s which
were all pixelated and terrible and on
modern screens they look
pretty ugly so if you're a professional
organization you might buy a
professional font
but for most of you in the room you'll
probably be looking at free fonts
and the good news is that in 2020 we
have a wealth of wonderfully designed
beautiful free fonts available
easily at fonts.google.com these are
some of my favorites
for data visualization i really like the
source family it has
a sans-serif variety serif variety
mono-spaced variety
and they're all available in lots of
weights and sizes
so next i want to touch a little bit
about hierarchy a typographic hierarchy
so a typographic hierarchy is just a way
of encoding an order of importance
in your type that helps to navigate your
readers through your chart or through
your document
and there's several ways to create
hierarchy so this is a case where we
have none
the easiest way to create hierarchy is
with size
but you can also do it with font weight
with color
with spacing you can do it with a
contrasting type
face or ideally a combination of all of
these things
and learning the rules of how to create
a hierarchy you know what are what
should you make your title versus your
subtitle versus your body text
is just a skill that takes a little bit
of practice but there are some more
specific tips in the
practical typography book that i
mentioned earlier
and finally i want to talk about numbers
a little bit so we use numbers all the
time in data visualization
some fonts have what's called old style
numbers i recommend you not use these
most of those fonts will also have
lining numbers which have all the same
x height and in a similar vein you also
want to choose a font that has
tabular numbers tabular numbers all have
the same width
so that when you make a table or
something all everything will line up in
a nice perfect column
so having covered the layout and the
typography
of a chart i want to talk a little bit
about the color everyone's favorite
topic
so there's a lot of tools out there i
know people are probably familiar with
things like color brewer
and there's other r packages that will
basically just choose a color
for you choose a color palette for you
but what i want to do today
is try to give you a little bit of
information that will hopefully help you
to
choose your own color palettes the truth
is though that color is really hard so i
don't want to lie to you and tell you
it's going to be easy
it's something i still struggle with and
it's just such a complex subject that it
takes a lot of practice
but i think there are a few things that
i can tell you today about color theory
and then a few sort of practical tips
to help improve your usage of color so
one of the chief complaints i get from
people is they say i just don't know
what colors look good together how do i
know what looks good together
this is a case where the color wheel can
really help you so
the color wheel like we all know from
grade school
it looks like this and uh there's
several types of palettes you can choose
from the color wheel that will usually
have colors that go well together
so if you want to choose a high contrast
palette you can choose a complementary
one that means opposite sides of the
color wheel
you can also choose analogous color
palettes which all come from the same
side of the color wheel
and there's triadic which are sort of
laid out in a triangle like this
and there's several other color palettes
as well
there's split complementary quadratic
and lots of others
and you can read a little bit more about
sort of the feeling that all these color
palettes give you but this is a nice way
to sort of get started if you're looking
to choose some hues
so once you choose those you might want
to adjust your colors a little bit and i
want to highlight the hsl color space so
this is a way of describing color
in contrast to something like rgb hsl
stands for the hue saturation and
lightness of a color so the hue is the
actual color itself
red green blue the saturation
is the amount of color you have there
and the lightness is how light or dark a
color is
so this is an example where we have a
red hue and if we turn down the
saturation you can see that it'll
basically drain all the color out of
there it's very dull
if we turn up the saturation it's going
to become very rich and vibrant
and if we turn down the lightness we can
see we still have a richness here but
now it's much darker
and if we turn it up it'll become more
lighter obviously
but you can see how this is a very easy
way when you pick a color and you say oh
but i wish it were a little bit lighter
or a little bit more saturated or less
saturated
this is a much more intuitive mental
model i think of how to adjust your
colors
and there's lots of online tools you can
use where you can stick it in and it'll
sort of
you know allow you to adjust the sliders
a little bit for your saturation and
lightness and such
so that was a little bit of the color
theory now some other practicalities of
how i choose color
um so i'm sort of a color pirate uh i
use my favorite tool in the world all
the time which is the eyedropper tool
so this is a tool if you're not familiar
it's present in all kinds of design
programs
and you can get apps on your computer on
my mac i like to use one called
colorslurp
on windows i like instant eyedropper
where you can just
click the tool pick any pixel on your
screen and it'll return the color for
you
so i use this all the time if i see a
data visualization for example that i
really like
where i love the color palette i'll just
take my eyedropper pick those colors
i do this with websites with photographs
and then i use the hsl sliders to adjust
the colors afterwards
a good example of this is this
generative conference badge that i
designed this summer
and i got the inspiration from my mom's
day planner so i went to visit my
parents and saw this day planner and i
really liked it so i just took a picture
of it
and when it came time to design the
graphic i took my eyedropper tool picked
all the colors i liked
adjusted them a little bit with the hsl
sliders and then
had my color palette and finally i want
to talk a little bit about backgrounds
so one thing i actually like a lot about
the
default ggplot theme is that it doesn't
use a white background
white backgrounds are not terrible
there's lots of you know there's a time
and place
but i think they're very overused
especially because white is a very harsh
color
especially on digital screens white is a
very aggressive and bright color
so i encourage you to sort of not
necessarily go straight to white as a
background
as a default and instead explore some
other options recently i've really liked
this sort of ivory color
a light gray color can also be very nice
or
dark backgrounds are fun to experiment
with but if you do go with a dark
background
just like i don't recommend a pure white
background all the time
i would be careful unless you have a
specific reason about choosing a pure
black background
so to review a little bit i've talked
about how you can establish a good
layout
in your data visualizations by creating
clean lines and symmetry
reducing clutter and increasing white
space
then you can use good fonts not use
system fonts
and establish a typographic hierarchy to
help guide readers through your
visualization
and then hopefully i have given you a
little bit of the tools that you need to
start
coming up with your own palettes and
choosing your own
color palettes and with that i will say
thank you
and that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so much will i um questions from
the audience
what tyler you can come get set up a
little if you want
um the first one is do you have any
specific recommendations for aesthetics
for maps
aesthetics for maps i mean essentially
all the same rules apply right
maps you want to try to reduce a lot of
times
the extraneous elements so maps often
have a lot of extraneous elements and
borders and such
in sometimes you're going for a thematic
map you actually might want to emphasize
those but if you're trying to go for a
very clean easy to read map
you have to think about that there's
also a lot to be considered in maps with
iconography
so using proper icons that help readers
identify whatever you're looking for
or using a really careful type
hierarchy so you have to really really
be careful about your type hierarchy and
spend a lot of time designing that for a
map since you have so many labels and so
much type
next one is um shouldn't a binding
constraint for color be colorblind
friendliness
yes absolutely it should um i didn't
have time to talk about this one of my
slides got cut for time
but another very important thing to do
in color is accessibility
so you should always be checking your
color palettes for color blindness and
also for contrast and there's easy
websites where you can do that
um why is it better for a title to be
left aligned instead of centered
the reason is mainly because in western
countries at least humans read
from the top left so that's where your
eye goes first on the page there's
several eye tracking studies that show
that your eye goes first
to the top left of the page and then to
the middle of the page and so putting
the title at the top
left is basically reducing the amount of
work that the reader has to do to get to
the information
um a couple more how long should one
typically spend on creating slash
designing a chart
how long does it typically take you to
create one
uh to create a simple design uh like
something i would do for fidelity you
know something that just needs to look
clean and
and readable i spend i don't know maybe
a couple hours designing a chart um
if i'm designing something more thematic
or something for
sort of a personal project something
more creative i mean it can take months
uh you know it's not all months of
sitting down just like designing
non-stop for eight hours a day but it's
months of
like laying in bed at 4am thinking about
colors
so that said uh thoughts on tufty themed
charts i like it question mark
that's all i'll say okay great um and
then
oh what tool has been used for creating
the presentation slides
the presentation slides were created
with keynote and let me emphasize
actually i want to clarify i like the
tough dr
markdown theme i don't always agree with
everything tufty says so tufty if you
read like his date of his books he has a
lot of
opinions i don't agree with all of those
but there's a tough dr markdown theme
that's based on some of his
writings which i really like and then
last one before
we let tyler get going is how do you
deal with viewers using monitors that
might render colors slightly differently
yeah that's a good question um i mean
there's very little you can do about
that to be honest i don't have a magical
solution to
change everyone's monitors for you all i
can say is that we are
lucky to live in 2020 when people have
most people have
more high resolution monitors so we can
use things like fonts that have a lot of
details in them and
you know nice color palettes but it's
tricky
great well thank you so much another
round of applause for will
all right thanks
you